[Aplausos]
eu sou caipira
a primeira vez que eu me deparei com
essa questão de diferença cultural não
pertencer a uma cultura sofrer bullying
foi o dia que eu sair da fazenda foi
estudar na cidade e chamei uma amiga pra
pousar lá em casa
isso é ser caipira
desde então na verdade muito antes disso
é só uma metáfora eu estudo a questão da
diferença
há 15 anos eu recebo estrangeiros que
vêm trabalhar no brasil enviou
brasileiros para trabalhar no exterior e
o meu trabalho é tentar fazer essas
pessoas se adaptarem
numa outra cultura o trabalho não é
fácil
vejam vocês os números que quando nós
estamos falando de executivos que já têm
um emprego ganham muito bem e tem que se
adaptar uma outra cultura trabalhar num
outro país somente um em cada quatro
obtenha o sucesso esperado pela empresa
normalmente quando a gente pensa
globalização mundo internacional isso é
chique isso é glamouroso isso é uma
oportunidade
é uma oportunidade mas é também um
grande desafio e não é um grande desafio
só para o executivo é um grande desafio
por exemplo pro público migrante
eu também faço trabalho mesmo
treinamento que oferece para os
executivos nas empresas
eu ofereci para os imigrantes e
refugiados recém-chegados no brasil
e garanto pra vocês os dois sofrem de
choque cultural
concomitantemente ao meu trabalho eu
estudo relações internacionais
eu sou formada e tem um mestrado na área
porque a grande questão das relações
internacionais sempre foi por que os
homens fazem guerra
eu tinha um álbum feeling de que essa
resposta estaria no campo da diferença
eu fui estudar alguns teóricos e talvez
só pra vocês
se nortear um nome muito importante é
todo o love
esse cara explica o seguinte mariana a
questão da diferença e da identidade é
desde sempre no ser humano
imaginem vocês o português encontrando o
indígena o indígena encontrando
português
a gente vai dizer que num primeiro
momento esse português olha para esses
indígenas em fala ou o que maravilha que
coisa diferente de mim eu nem sabia que
isso existia eo indígena da mesma
maneira quando ele olha para o português
existem muitas teorias com o brasil
indígena nem conseguia reconhecer o
português como homem como ser humano
de tão diferente que essas caravelas
chegando do mar algo que eles nunca
tinham visto que era um paralelo pensem
o ct chegando na terra hoje como é que
vocês lidariam com isso certamente seria
o golo mas peraí
e agora que eu faço com esse e te porque
ele pode ser mal
ele pode querer tomar o meu lugar ele
pode querer ser mais forte que eu então
historicamente o ser humano quando em
contato com a diferença ele primeiro se
maravilha mas depois a identidade dele
entre o questionamento ele sente
insegurança ele sente incerteza e aí ele
sente 2 ímpetos colonizar o outro ou
ignorar a existência do outro porque
quando em contato com o desconhecido a
gente quer controlar esse desconhecido
eu fui estudar isso lá nas relações
internacionais para entender que isso
acontece com qualquer casal
já a gente primeiro se a mais para jonas
agentes e maravilha com a diferença e
passados alguns seis meses
a gente está lá tentando fazer o outros
e como a gente porque a gente quer ter
controle daquela parte do outro que a
gente não conhece e que a gente nunca
vai ter controle ou seja eu estou aqui
para dizer hoje pra vocês que o
relacionamento de nós humanos com a
diferença
ele é historicamente muito difícil
existe uma charge que eu acho que ajuda
muito a gente pensar isso estão vendo a
ocidental que ocidental está pensando da
muçulmana tudo coberto exceto os olhos
que sociedade machista cruel mas o que a
muçulmana está pensando do ocidental
nada coberto exceto os olhos que
sociedade machista cruel
nesse lugar é onde eu tenho uma proposta
de que é possível a gente olhar para o
diferente de uma outra maneira porque se
vocês olharem dentre essa chade
vocês vão perceber que o ser humano
passa séculos lutando julgando a
construção da diferença do outro sendo
que existe algo muito mais intrínseco
que nos une que é por exemplo no caso da
charge a sociedade machista cruel
nesse sentido o interculturalismo que é
a área que o trabalho vai dizer o
seguinte se essas duas mulheres tivessem
tido a oportunidade de ao invés de se
julgarem sentarem e conversarem e
conhecerem as histórias uma da outra
essas mulheres teriam uma possibilidade
de lidar de maneira diferente com a
diferença porque o sofrimento nos une e
todos nós sofremos
então a minha área vai trazer a seguinte
frase pra vocês um inimigo é aquele cuja
história você ainda não escutou eu e
mariana hoje diante de vocês sou caipira
entre a culturalista branca e
homossexual eu poderia
segundo as minhas teorias poderia não eu
deveria estar sentindo imenso medo de
estar me relacionando com vocês e tenho
certeza que do lado de vocês vocês
também sentem medo de se relacionar
comigo e eu me coloco aqui diante de
vocês hoje
ouçam a minha história eu quero ouvir a
história de vocês
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]